non merci merci aux parents et à
monsieur frank gretz serre merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur je souhaite d'ailleurs y
associer thierry solère ainsi que mes
collègues franciliens
chaque jour plusieurs millions de
franciliens en prêtent les réseaux sncf
et ratp qui desservent un grand nombre
de communes d'île de france
au delà des conditions de transport
parfois exécrables dont sont souvent
victimes les usagers
je veux évoquer la sécurité et la
tranquillité à bord de ses trains sur de
trop nombreuses lignes comme la
tristement célèbre ligne p qui dessert
la seine-et-marne les passagers
subissent en permanence des incivilités
et des agressions commises dans une
impunité quasi totale de leurs auteurs
consommation de tabac et de stupéfiants
dégradations de matériel agressions
verbales ou physiques
voilà le quotidien de nombreux
franciliens pourtant monsieur le
ministre
des solutions existent c'est le cas de
la proposition de loi savary voté à
l'unanimité sur nos bancs et promulguée
cette année un texte d'ailleurs
largement renforcée par les
contributions des élus les républicains
et notamment par la nouvelle président
de la région ile-de-france valérie
pécresse
l'article 4 de cette loi donne la
possibilité aux agents de sécurité de la
sncf et de la ratp d'effectuer des
patrouilles en civil qui faciliterait
qui faciliteront la prise en compte des
flagrants délits tout ceci dans un seul
et unique objectif que les auteurs de
ces infractions soit enfin sanctionné
monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui les dac les décrets
d'application ne sont toujours pas
publié pouvait donc nous nous préciser
quand sera concrètement mise en oeuvre
cette disposition
et quand seront publiés les décrets
d'application de cette loi qui permettra
de lutter efficacement contre la fraude
la violence et les incivilités dans nos
transports en commun la parole est à
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député vous avez raison à la fois de
rappeler l'importance pour nos
concitoyens de la sécurité dans les
transports il suffit de rappeler le
chiffre de plus de 10 millions de
personnes qui chaque jour utiliser les
transports en commun vous a vu aussi
raison de rappeler le travail qui a
parlementaire qui a été fait est que le
gouvernement accompagné très fortement
et qui a conduit à l'adoption de la loi
dite savary et à travers lui je veux
remercier l'ensemble du parlement cette
loi était promulguée au journal officiel
le 22 mars dernier dans cette loi il y à
des dispositions qui sont d'application
immédiate et d'autres qui suppose des
textes d'application
je veux rappeler que en ce qui concerne
les textes qui sont d'application
immédiate il n'y a notamment toutes les
mesures qui renforcent les pouvoirs des
structures de sécurité interne puisque
nous avions constaté malheureusement que
les services de sécurité de la sncf mais
aussi de la ratp ne disposait pas d'un
certain nombre de pouvoirs et notamment
ceux de pouvoir contrôler les bagages
des personnes dans les trains
deuxièmement nous avons également donner
de nouveaux pouvoirs aux officiers de
police judiciaire qui sont des pouvoirs
notamment de pouvoir faire des
inspections visuelles des bagages ou des
fouilles dans les véhicules les emprises
immobilières de transport public de
voyageurs
c'est aussi d'application immédiate nous
avons aussi donné des nouveaux pouvoirs
à d'autres acteurs vous savez que les
agents municipaux
là je parle de fraude pourront
dorénavant aussi intervenir il reste des
questions notamment celles que vous
évoquez sur la possibilité
d'interventions en civil nous avons
saisi le conseil d'état et le
gouvernement espère avoir la réponse du
conseil d'état pour publier cet arrêté
le plus rapidement possible la loi a été
publiée le 22 mars le parlement
d'adopter rapidement une question
essentielle pour le gouvernement que
nous suivons avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et je pense que en
l'occurrence tous ceux qui critiquent
les pouvoirs publics devraient
reconnaître que ici les estuaires dollar